voilà pour une partie de cette
intervention Armelle charrier bonjour en
décrypte ensemble ce discours qui a été
attendu on s'attendait d'ailleurs ces
derniers jours à une riposte rue c'est
ce qu'ils vont contre-attaquer ou pas
par cette prise de parole oui ça fait
beaucoup d'hommes 300000 hommes des
réservistes des professionnels donc pour
résumer oui on a un chiffre qui est en
deçà du nombre de réservistes que compte
la Russie 300 000 parce que derrière il
y a une spécificité que vous avez montré
du doigt c'est-à-dire que ce sont des
gens qui savent ce savent combattre et
que derrière ils vont avoir des
formations militaires pour éviter en
fait Vladimir Poutine d'avoir une sorte
de boucherie où il y avait après la
tchécini ou l'Afghanistan c'est maire de
soldats assez babouchka qui ont vu les
dépouilles de leurs enfants arriver et
qui se sont elles soulevées donc il y a
cette précaution effectivement qui est
mise en place l'application est
immédiate on ne fait pas venir de des
petites vidéos qu'on voit de Russie là
en ce moment où on voit effectivement là
à la police aller chercher des
réservistes et partir donc il y a
effectivement cette mobilisation qui met
en place Vladimir Poutine qui à la fois
prendre cours parce que du coup il
renforce avec une capacité d'être sur le
terrain militaire comme cadirof derrière
le Tchétchène qui se compare pour lui a
rappelé aussi à ses troupes à aller
recruter à aller chercher et à venir en
renfort mais il n'a pas demandé la
mobilisation générale pour ne pas mettre
le pays en émoi parce que la réaction
des Russes évidemment compte dans ce
dans ce contexte il y a des réactions de
différentes chancellerie elles ont
absolument pas tardé Londres voit dans
dans ses propos un aveu d'échec de
l'invasion russe les Américains eux
carrément parlent d'un signe de de
faiblesse comment interpréter cette
cette réponse de Vladimir Poutine à
l'Occident alors on peut le lire de deux
manières on peut aussi bien lire sur le
fait que il y a la volonté de dire c'est
parce qu'il a perdu terrain militaire
que il est obligé aujourd'hui de faire
appel à ces référendums qu'il est obligé
de faire appel à cette mobilisation
qu'il est obligé d'aller employer les
termes de l'harmonie nucléaire quand il
dit que on arme l'Occident arme
énormément les ukrainiens et qu'à un
moment donné il peut utiliser toutes les
armes et que la Russie a toutes les
armes donc on comprend à quoi il fait
l'usure mais on peut aussi considérer
que dans la logique de Vladimir Poutine
il veut aujourd'hui réussir sa guerre et
voir comment est-ce qu'il sort de cette
guerre et il a rencontré ces derniers
jours les leaders effectivement qui
étaient chinois indiens ou même turc et
grosso modo le message qui lui a été
fourni c'est il faudrait quand même
finir avec la galère parce que derrière
l'économie empathie parce que les liens
que l'on peut tisser ensemble sont plus
compliqués à tenir économiquement aussi
s'entendre parce que derrière il y a
tout un réflexion sur une économie
rouble yuan etc qui se met en place et
derrière remobiliser des hommes des
professionnels demandaient à ce qu'il y
ait des référendums pour justement avoir
une assise j'allais dire de terrain à
débattre si il venait à discuter avec
Zelinski et certainement une réflexion
simplement la chose qu'on peut pas
oublier c'est que là tout de suite
Vladimir Poutine joue aussi j'allais
dire son aura et sa capacité à rester en
Russie donc ça dure sans durcissement de
terminologie quand effectivement il fait
pas l'alarme nucléaire et toujours un
peu inquiétante dans ce genre de
circonstances tout ces réactions